hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to rogue legacy
this is
the game after i've been playing for
about a hundred and some odd hours i
have become addicted to this game and
i've been playing it ever since i did
the last episode also thank you to epic
games for once again sponsoring this
video link down in the description use
code markiplier on the epic game store
for supporting me whenever you make a
purchase like this game rogue legacy 2
which i highly recommend because it is
unbelievably fun or any other game in
the epic game store so what i'm gonna do
in this video is i'm gonna show you
every boss and i'm gonna try to beat
them all in one life
and if i can't do that then i have
failed miserably and i am not worthy of
anything but before i gotta do that i
gotta get out of here
as you can see some of the enemies are
different i actually have there's an
upgrade that makes this area harder
um but
you know the difficulty is in the
enemies but also these things are now
three wheels instead of two
also i've learned a few tricks like
dashing backwards hey it's not important
i i'ma tell you what is important once
we get to the boss
because the boss even the first one is
new and uh more difficult than he was
before
but we're not worried about that right
now we gotta get to these places in the
first place whoa
i might do my best i always i i don't
really die against the bosses anymore
but i do die against being stupid out
here and i know that whenever i'm
playing and i'm talking at the same time
it reduces my iq incredibly also i have
two jumps now
and two dashes
i could have more but i don't like
having more than two because it because
i it's too hard for me to count above
two and also i try to use my spells a
bit more than i have in the past
which is new for me i know
definitely wasn't much for a spell user
also this guy's ability to shield is
incredible i don't know why i wasn't
using it before
it's complete immunity and you get
invulnerability frames which is just
nice
also i'm not too concerned about the
gold i have most of the upgrades anyway
huh what strange paintings by the way
these are enemies
i run into them
so much
i hate them
and i you wouldn't think because as soon
as you look at you're like oh yeah that
ain't right i run into him
all the time not worth it i i literally
will do that i'll be like it's not worth
it
not because i couldn't fight it with no
damage but because it would just take so
long because they float around and i
don't have time to look at them so i
don't look at them this is stupid
they're stupid and i think everything
about them is stupid
and i hate them
because they're stupid i've been up
there speaking of stupid
hey
the only problem is when there's so many
things on screen that it's hard to see
what's coming i have to like relax my
eyes and look at it look at it all like
in general they even see a projectile
coming at me
[Music]
um well also what i have here is an
ability to reroll these uh that would be
great it'd make it a lot riskier though
i only use it for classes that i have
like umpteen bajillion health with and i
haven't gotten any health boost so far
so i doubt i'm gonna get any more it
means you do 100 more damage so twice as
much damage but you take twice as much
damage so essentially look at my health
and say that instead of 3600 i have half
of that which is
which is not as much as i would like to
have
if i'm going to try to kill all the
bosses and i do enough damage anyway so
i'll just take this which is okay it's
more damage on spin kicks but i never
really spin kick anyway there he is
here's our man
so this is the upgraded version of the
boss that you saw in the other video or
maybe if you didn't see that video this
guy's a tough boss but not that tough
he's actually pretty easy
you'll notice that he's gold which is
the biggest difference
oh god yeah not where i wanted to be for
that
so he generally just he does the same
moves but they all have different
effects like this goes there and
oh don't
ah i thought that was gonna hit me and
then he does this
but you can get rid of it with that
block there
what are you doing oh that
yeah he's okay though
yep
so long as i can time those properly god
damn it ah i tried to chase him down for
that other hit that i didn't get
you can also spin kick them to get rid
of
those orbs but i find it easier to just
do the block
come at me
oh god my invincibility
oh god it's not i forgot it was on
cooldown oh that's dumb of me
hey big fire
oh god this is a terrible place to be
thank goodness that was ready
oh
no see if i had that other item by now i
would be one hit from death and i don't
like being one hit from death i've
pulled some incredible stuff out of my
ass being one hit from death but i would
rather not be there right now
god that's the wrong place to be
don't do it
don't spike me
and you're dead
oh
talk about celebrating before the finish
god damn it
i get hit
i don't like getting hit
i don't like it getting hit usually
means you get dead
god damn it of course i was
that's going to be the story of this run
is it's going to be complete
overconfidence and i am not going to
make it all the way to the end beat all
six bosses
but we'll find out okay where to next
boss i think i'm gonna go up so the only
way for me to regain health
is food and
that's about it but i do have an item i
didn't even talk about it but i do have
an item that allows me to get eight
percent chance of health drops from
enemies when killed
which is very much nicer than it even
sounds and it sounds pretty much nice
so already i'm almost at full health and
there's another one i'm basically full
health this is the zone where i am the
most of just like it's not worth
fighting those that painting in that
chest oh that's that's a real chest
not worth it
i just don't bother i'm on my way what
is this one oh watch what i can do here
hi
i am so lucky that the fire wasn't there
when i did that i am just pure lucky
what are you doing stop it stop it get
some help this is a mimic and i hate him
wow that's
why
you
[ __ ]
what are you doing to me you're making
me look bad you're making me look bad
and i don't like looking bad the other
reason i want to show you this because
some of these bosses are just
ridiculously cool there we go this is a
health bonus i don't know if i saw this
in the first episode that i made you
take damage but you gain maximum life
and because i have an item that's going
to heal me up from
see i almost ran into that guy
like an idiot
when you have groups of enemies it's
kind of important to prioritize who you
can attack and when because if you're
just waiting for an attack on the one in
front of you you're gonna miss an
opportunity to hit
something around you
do not
yeah
the real treasure chest shine they
sparkle in the light
i've gotten so used to seeing like their
animations and what they do when they're
doing it that it just causes this jolt
of adrenaline whenever i see it out of
the corner of my eye
hey
this is uh
oh oh man that's a bad start to this
this is a mini boss
uh it's you need to beat these ones in
order to get to the next boss
then there's one more after this i think
it's pretty cool i like having a mini
bosses before bosses that's fun
i was attacking the other one but sure
you can have a turn
oh that's not what i blocked
one's almost dead
this is why i kill one of them first is
because
you don't want to be waiting on the
other one
to do
have more opportunities to hurt you
if you're only if you're trying to
attack both
and with
two too many hits on that i beat it
shouldn't have taken those but whatever
by the way if it wasn't clear i [ __ ]
love this game i love this game so much
i really love the first rogue legacy but
i actually went back to play it again
after playing this one for a lot
and it's astonishing the difference
between it like i knew that graphically
it was better but just looking
at the sheer amount
i'm hitting this because i need a health
and i just
want nope the sheer
difference
and yet similarity that is main oh you
[ __ ] of a painting
you oh this is a terrible place to be
i hate this place get me out of here
okay that's what you call
uh a hell room and i don't like being in
that room and i don't want to be in that
room ever again please never get me in
that room
oh god no wham
take some of me
oh god what is this place
it's hammer hell
jeez
what's with all the hammers oh no i
didn't want that
there we go if i had to hit them with
that sooner i didn't realize there were
so many of them fungal spores my spell
and it's good because it allows you to
when it goes off it hits everything in
the area so if there's a big cluster of
enemies like that it's very handy
because you can take them all out at
once and they just explode i see oh my
god i saw the painting for some reason
the giant purple ball was
just invisible to me
wow
that is the i am
i swear i'm better than this okay this
is achilles shield 10
more damage at above fifty percent
health honestly it's kind of
not that much but ten percent is ten
percent this is defeated with a critical
hit restore six percent of my health
which is very good and if i didn't have
body buffet i would do this one because
this one basically guarantees that
you're going to stay at full health so
long as you crit which i crit a lot
however i have only a certain amount of
resolve left i have 205 total resolve
and i need to make sure i have a little
bit left so that i can do some of the
things in the bottom base which actually
require resolve or else i'm going to be
walking around with very low health
this is good 20 more critical damage
that's good and it's cheap so i get that
i know a lot of this is probably going
over your head but just trust me when i
say
this game is dope
link in the description
just get this game it's so much fun
it's you will get so much
out of it
like it's just
the most entertaining game
that i've played in a long long time if
you even remotely like
roguelike games
roguelite games
like this is just such a good one it's
such a good one
i'm just gonna shoot that up there
i knew it i knew it i knew there was
stuff up there get dead anything that
can shoot arrows down straight below
is the bane of my existence anything
else wanna tussle oh
wow i thought that was a real one
well you're gonna die just because i
don't take that lightly
see it's literally just stupid mistakes
that'll get you every
single
time
oh i hate this room i don't even know
what this room is
give me that
stop no
i press the wrong button i'm sorry or i
brain farted i don't know which
oh there's a commander down there
somewhere
they're they're all blue because they're
shielded
and the shielding is from a commander
down below now the question is do i want
to kill it well i don't want to be too
much of a coward
who's oh it's just one of these no
that's easy
well
hey
come on
there we go okay i i'm looking for one
last mini boss before i
see i have to really think i'm like
no i gotta give one last uh mini boss
before
i can continue on to
i'm gonna duh i'm fine
uh before i can continue to uh where i
need to go hell yeah more health i love
this i should have gotten the double
damage if i see it again i will get it
no i won't that's a lie why would i do
that my hubris i have never beaten a
boss with that thing because the instant
i do like i think too much like okay
double damage i can't get hit and i get
hit so much
it's the one you see this white at the
bottom of that purple box i'm looking at
a mini map the entire thing here
this is the one door i haven't looked
and i'm willing to bet you
that's got what i'm looking for in it
oh no it doesn't
down below it does do though
yep there it is
always break as many objects as you can
just do
i get hit on spikes so much i do not
take them lightly ever
you gotta make your way through all this
before you'll get to uh
oh thank goodness i have two
dashes before you can get to the end
you the boss is the one throwing all of
these fyi
just take some maneuvering and you'll be
here no problem okay
you're an a-hole a year and a-half
a year and a hole
year there you go
okay this is uh i wouldn't really call
this a mini-boss it's like an obstacle
course
it's kind of fun though it's a change of
pace
i like it
bam
and it's dead and that will never curse
me anymore ever
now with the skills i've learned with
these fights i shall take the fight to
the boss
not right now i unlocked this boss i'm
not gonna go for this boss because in
the hierarchy of bosses this one is
harder than other bosses or i ain't no
[ __ ] and i'll go fight it you know i
would because i kind of want the safety
net of like other relics or other things
like that i know this be the end of my
video too quickly i can feel myself
getting ready to choke i'm gonna go
to another boss i'll be back in a bit
i'll be back i'm gonna go down here to
unlock the teleporter but i'm not gonna
go down because this place is
well i ain't no [ __ ] and now would be a
good time to go for it
because i have higher resolve so let's
let's do this one
it really doesn't matter what order you
do it first like technically this place
is quote unquote harder
okay and it is
i say as i get hit immediately
yes this is what i need
so in here
is a key that costs 40 resolve to hold
and if your hell if your resolve goes
below 100
you lose that percentage of health now
this one is okay because eventually i
will be able to get rid of it by
unlocking a gate which it goes to and
then i will get my resolve back and i'll
get my health back
but if i already have low i already have
low resolve before even going in there
because i got a relic that i was like oh
my god i have that relic
then i don't want to be caught with my
pants down
is this to this one no this is the black
key gate oh
there we go
oh
man why do you got to be the twin
wardrobes
i'll do
a triposis
atropos i bet this one is the boss room
and i bet these are what i'm looking for
okay cool
i gotta i gotta
it means i gotta clear some of this
stuff i don't want to but i really
should if i wanna be responsible
uh to my future self
don't i missed it by that much
i hate you those suck
oh
i hit the slime
oh god
well that was milt il mill timed
can you just please
thank you
you cost me two hits
why are you shielded
you are not shielded
vulnerable oh this is not where i want
to be
just come down here buddy it's safe down
here
there's only a certain range on the
dude's shield whoever is shielding him
so uh
who is doing the sh i don't want to
fight you
no thank you okay and this is what i'm
looking for bam
this is another mini boss and by many
boss it's just big hammer man
whoa hey what are you doing there pal
much like the other one it's best to go
after just one first
whoever wants to volunteer
looks like knifey is volunteering
oh yeah
yeah no yeah you do three
well i'm doing the thing that i didn't
want to do which is hitting both of them
all the same time
with no thought
the strategy or nothing you do three i
always forget
okay well that's
i always forget to do the the
if you want to stay up attacking an
enemy in the sky you swinging spin jump
swing spin and i i've never really done
it
because i'm bad at this game
but you know i it's it's like a lot of
these tactics
that are probably pretty common on
higher level playing is just like i'm
just figuring it all out on my my own so
i'm very slow to the uptake on them
santa oh also it's like christmas theme
i i didn't even realize it like
everything is christmas scene because
they had a holiday update so
to me like these things look perfectly
normal but to you they pro i wasn't
looking
oh you're still alive of course you are
oh god see this is what happens i i look
away for one second
and then i just absolutely beef it
but i will not beef
you get to live buddy
you get to live i have the key
and wouldn't you guess it it's more of
these dudes but this was the worst one
actually because it's got
a shield here and the shield is terrible
because of the thing that he just did
which is why i'm going to
kill him first ah
i
wish upon a star
i say with confidence
don't
all right maybe i'll kill the axe first
just because he's actually present in
the fight
no
i don't want to
i see that's what i'll do every time
i try to be fancy with it and i get hit
oh my god okay this is dumb
i'm being an idiot
this is what happens i i talk and i goof
and i'm
the goof turns into real not goofness
and oh
my god i literally am looking away oh
what's happening to me everybody i'm
changing into a scrub lord
i'm sorry i'm sorry everybody i'm sorry
i'm sorry i didn't mean it but that's
both of these that's all four mini
bosses both in the top towers and the
bottom towers done i don't have to worry
about them anymore now the next thing
that i'm going to do is actually fight
this boss
here
i'm going to kick its ass
because
why
i can
that's why
hello
hi dragon get ready to get your ass
kicked
or is it something else
it's the dude inside the dragon it's
very warm in here i had to open the
window benefit also is i heal up every
time i go into a boss fight
this is the sixth boss in this current
leg of the game
and estuary trouble
is a bit of a [ __ ] but he's not as bad
as
uh the hard mode of this other boss that
exists
and that i'm gonna save that dude for
last because the oh i definitely
i definite
i definitely
stop
trying to defend your boss or something
trying to get brownie points
in the second phase which he just
launched oh
you yeah
oh i thought i could
thought i was gonna get the perfect
because uh technically you can do that
to do more damage
if you're wow i
press the complete wrong buttons there i
don't even know what i was doing
what was i going for ah don't do it
50 is better than nothing
oh my god am i about to scrub this up
i think i'm about to scrub it up
guys
i hate to say it but i might be oh my
god
whoa
no
oh i can't let this happen
not this boss
no no no no no no no no
no no no no what
okay
that's the adds down you [ __ ]
oh my god i tried to bomb him so i could
get damaged that's why those numbers
were so big there did you see the big
numbers that's what i was doing because
i tried to i knew i had the health and i
could shield bomb i just timed it wrong
and only got half damage reduction but
it's fine because i still kicked his ass
all right
i don't know why i had so much trouble
on that one i really don't know why i
just got hit way more than i ever should
have that was embarrassing
but hey
cause like that fight i i thought i had
pretty down but
i got him that's all that matters
it's fine
now i'm gonna go to this next area
that's going to lead me down this road
of like chung chung boss and then it'll
be boss boss boss this is i forget what
it's called i never know the names of
these places because i don't pay
attention enough
oh
mini bullet hell over here
you know maybe i'll just go over it yeah
you know what i'll go over it why was i
going through it but in the middle of
this area is the access to the fifth
zone which is called
that's the sun tower
it's a great place i go up here because
i wanted to unlock the teleporter and
see if there were any yes healables
yeah milk and cookies
okay whatever
but i'm not going here
trust me i'll get to the bosses soon
yo
what are you doing here big guy
all right you know just for the sake of
you've inconvenienced out maybe i won't
i just wanted you to die because
i sometimes take it personally when
things hit me like that
it's
they're just mean and i just think that
they should die is that so wrong
is it
oh man it is not gonna give me anything
nice this one definitely not because
having a two second cooldown on this
having to wait two seconds in between
each swing i can do way more than two
swings per second um for this one i
guess i don't need to worry about the
platform it would be convenient to get
rid of some projectiles i i this one's
new this was in the christmas update i
haven't used it a lot but sometimes it
does help me and save me from a few
projectiles here and there
that i ordinarily wouldn't get hit by
and it's completely useless in like the
final final boss but in some of those
bosses i do believe it does block some
and it's relatively cheap so why not
why not
bam that's what it does it creates that
little like
like
little puff as i land
the only problem is that it can also
destroy platforms that i am on
which isn't nearly as fun
that's nice this outtake this is 75 more
damage every six hit
which equates to like what a 16
something percent damage increase better
than that other one
ah something's in my eye
what's in my eye
what's this a fairy room i don't need it
says on the minimap that's how i knew
i can't see i only got one eye
peripheral vision is gone
okay i'm back now
this is the next boss
and he's a fun one he and his
crew
this fruit makes beerus might have no
idea how to pronounce your name fire
areth
biarith he shoots big bones
it's really not that bad like
legitimately uh
not lying not that bad
oh only what the there was only one
cannibal that was weird oh big
bones block
get blocked
yeah
that's a nice big bone you got there
don't do it
i like to try i don't know why but my
instinct is always just to try to reason
with
the bosses before they inevitably try to
hit me
i think it's only fair
you know you never know it worked in
undertale so hey maybe communication is
the key
so that thing's still in my eye well
here i am switching bosses again
ah
don't do it
quartermaster how far
i can't hang on i can't oh my god what
is it my eye
ah
the [ __ ] is in my eye
am i okay
is my eye good
okay anyway
well i dodged those apparently all right
he's dead forever which is exactly good
and he'll never come back oh wait it's
hard mode
hi he's got friends
hey go away
and they were scrubs to the end
that's what i thought
i'm coming in
ah damn
that's the wrong timing on that
i guess you're done for too bad you
don't have any friends
they're chumps they're jumps through and
through
straight up chump down
huh and just like that that boss was
easy
that was the hard mode by the way the
hard mode added those ads and a few
other things
but just like that goes down
easy peasy that's three of six bosses
down three of six and then we open up
the next biome which is a snowy land
the kurgulian plateau the kergul
the kerguelen plateau
the kirkland
the crogley
the krugglestone
the the krampel ambulance hey who could
think i got this fart with me
and for this area you need these things
which are called lily of the valley you
need two of them to open the boss's
doors because she likes flowers
and you offer them to her and then you
kill her
it's a perfectly viable strategy to hit
something that's and then go out of the
zone it's not cowardly at all anyone
that says otherwise is stupid hey look
it's the other lily
[Music]
excuse me sirs and mams
i need to be through this area
can we get a replay on how
millimeter pixel perfect my dodge was
there
is this the right way this does not feel
right
i've been playing this enough to i was
right i don't know what i'm talking
about i'm an idiot so i haven't been
playing this enough to anything and i'll
shut up all right your offering is
excerpted the lilies have been taken and
it's boss time this boss is the hard
mode of the boss that you have not seen
but she's fine so long as i can do the
spin attack thing
which
you guys know is my strong suit
nothing's gonna blow
this is gonna blow me
i'm blowing it
ah i'm in a corner
oh god oh my god
i am truly terrible at this game
oh did not see the explosion the only
the most important thing that i
definitely needed to avoid
all right easy peasy whoa what are you
doing
ah i'm still not quite getting it right
i had that one on that last hit there
but
yeah there we go
oh
look at me oh god look at those
okay this is pretty much the same as the
other one except now there are those
things around which admittedly i've been
hit by more times than i would like to
admit
oh god i jumped into it
why would i do that it always
to
take care of the things that might
damage you
before it has a chance to do said i
didn't i didn't do the thing i was
trying to dramatically do
just takes me a second to warm up to it
i swear
trust me guys i'm just getting warmed up
okay she's one hit but don't get cocky
she's more than one hit apparently don't
get cocky
and voila ignore the first half of that
fight i don't know what happened i don't
know who that man was
i don't know who he was this is the one
i'm actually worried about for some
reason i get hit by this guy so much i
don't know why
but i do
he's not that hard it's not that
complicated a fight it has a lot of
phases and it's long but he's he moves
very slow
and this is what i don't like okay and
we're just gonna eat that i guess
oh my god this is this is this is how it
is
this is what i do
and he does that
he borrows a little thing from his
sister or something i don't know there's
some lore here
got dodge out of that
he's doing his thing
i'm gonna not be hit by it and take a
revenge swipe
with bonus damage
i did not take damage on that by the way
that was a perfect block it's gold when
it's perfect he's doing it again
and he'll do the shadows
perfect reason to get in close pal
oh always always i always misjudged the
distance on his swirling purple balls
nope i don't want it
oh well i can't exactly go through that
gets hit b oh no me get hit oh my god
are you serious
oh
i'm sorry i'm sorry that's how i screw
everything up i always do [ __ ] like that
i'm like he's almost dead get him get
him instead of just being calm and and
like this oh it's not the reward that's
because he's not really dead
what are you doing
what are you doing buddy my spin kicks
have been upgraded you don't stand a
chance
so this is the true and like i said i
hate oh my god are you kidding me here
we come
perfect perfect block perfect
oh my god no
i had a perfect block there
okay anyway i gotta concentrate the
problem is that i'm jabbering
i'm jabbering so much
okay here we go
perfect block perfect lock [ __ ]
you
[ __ ]
god damn it if i die to this i'm gonna
be so mad oh
here we go
i just gotta watch closely
be careful
strike when i can not when i can't
and he'll go down
in
no time
i wasn't risking the dash strikes
underneath him first
because i just didn't want to be too
fancy with it but when you go under him
you want to dash strike because you'll
crit as you go through him and that's
that boss that's five bosses of six dead
this next boss is so goddamn hard
spike's boss literally came out with
this most recent update and i haven't
had too much practice with him and i
gotta get to him first which is the
bigger problem because i am obviously
low on health man
if i die not even on the boss but going
to the bar oh oh my god i said the thing
and i'm doing the thing
is this a boss why are you here
oh it's a it's a not a mini bot well i
guess you could call it a mini boss
can you stop loading up this space i
have my stompy farts i forgot i have
stompy farts
always be worried about what's coming
out of the periphery because you
literally never know oh god why did i
i [ __ ] spun kick it instead of
slashing it
i can't i can't risk like a single hit
here
risk that thank you for the food would
have been terrible if i had gotten hit
by you
that thing hits harder than anything oh
i forgot i have stompy feet well this is
unfortunate
take my i leave now goddammit the food
oh my god that's the price of being a
coward
all right you know what's screwed i've
got enough i've got enough uh health to
make a run for it and i will heal the
full oh my god don't
sir
i think this is gonna go yeah this goes
all the way i think oh no
why would you put that there
oh this terrible place to be
all i gotta do is get up here and boom
i'm at the boss
okay
this is where i could make or break
literally everything um
this is the final boss of this it's not
the final boss of the game because
remember the game is still in early
access
but
it's make it or break it like right here
so if i'm very quiet on this boss and
yes everything is very cool looking and
everything is very fun and everything is
very crisp and everything is just like
it's great this boss is like a step
above it's so cool what this guy does
and the the stages the the normal mode
is fine it's very cool but the hard mode
is nuts
you're about to see it and i'm really
hoping that i can beat it i'm
not 100 of my ability to beat this on
the first try
yes the noises help oh my god
oh cool down goddamn
can not do that
okay phase one down phase one just phase
one
this phase two
now the important thing is everything is
very small you gotta like charge the
things you're trying to kill immediate
oh god
you know what i said all those lessons
about target switching and all that jazz
oh my god ah i meant the freaking
i can't talk right now oh my god
yeah everything's so small
okay
phase two done
oh
okay
oh my god i cannot do that
oh my god i'm gonna
totally lose it i'm oh
oh
oh my god
now
oh wow
i have to hit
what
i'm supposed to be immune between phases
i'm supposed to be oh my god okay
this is
i have one hit on the hardest phase
let's do it
[Music]
oh
if that one
hit before i went to the next phase
didn't happen or if i didn't just
absolutely cheese it
all over that other
phase
i would have been done
oh that hurts so bad
no
oh
all right i'm not giving up i'm gonna
kick that boss's ass
i didn't unlock any teleporters either
which means that i have to run all the
way back to wherever the hell he is
okay this is it all right
whoa hey fiery
ah come on
god damn it if i die
before i get there i'm gonna be so mad
i'm gonna be beyond mad
oh good thing boxer can walk through
things
boxer is great because uh you can
actually walk through a lot of enemies
no not like this not like this no not
like this oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god
oh
what the hell
what the hell is wrong with you no not
like this
[Applause]
[Music]
i
i i don't know what happened i'm gonna
shut up
stop talking and i'm just gonna go and
do my thing
okay i've made it back to the boss but
that's no guarantee of success because
i've made it clear that i have no shield
i'm gonna go back to the beginning and
i'm gonna actually try to prepare
properly by getting there's one more
relic out in the open that i can get and
if it's a damaged one then i'm in good
shape and i could get milk
i like milk
oh that'll do
oh
i should just go for the scissors i
should just i crit a lot i should just
go for the scissors they're damaged in
front of me i would have two scissors if
i just grabbed them
god damn it
god damn it you [ __ ] spin kick [ __ ]
god i don't need stronger spin kicks
okay
it's time to go back to the boss i did
what i could to go get some relics they
don't exist
they they don't i've seen i've seen so
many relic rooms and none of them had
anything that i really wanted i found
one milk
that's enough for me
i'm gonna kick this boss's ass
and that's all there is to it
no hits phase one done
this class is good because his dodge
is like
very low cooldown
it's like two seconds which is so
helpful
whoa i saw that freaking
that freaking whoa
that freaking arrow coming in from
downtown over there
wow
look at that garbage
and that's phase two down
still full health
oh didn't see that one
no one got three but that's okay
oh
how did i miss that i don't know
or how did i not miss that
i guess it would be better
oh i almost missed you at the bottom
down there
got him phase three done and you still
hit me
okay
this is the last face
ah damn it
gotta remember my role
so
i'm not hitting as many times as i could
hit i'm being a little bit cautious here
for obviously good reason
given my history with this guy
oh my god
yes
that's
more like it
that's better that's better that's
better that's what you call better
all right that took an hour longer than
i thought it would but hey
i did it
it's quite a bullet hell that last one
it is quite a bullet hell but that is
the sixth and final boss of early access
rogue legacy
beaten
and then the golden doors what lurks
behind it
ah nothing because it's not ready yet
the full game will come out sometime
next year
but when i first played this when it
first came out like a year and a half
ago for early access it was barely
anything like this first castle now is
it so there wasn't a lot but there's so
much more because not only all the
bosses but those were the hard mode
bosses and the six boss the blacksmith
guy he doesn't even have a hard mode yet
he's just hard so
very fun
very
very fun and that's all the time i got
for now thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know what you thought
down the comments below give this game a
try it is so good it is just so
unbelievably fun link is in the
description below use code markiplier on
the epic game store to support me when
you purchase it or any other game that
you purchase on the epic game store
thank you to epic games for sponsoring
this video and thank you all so much for
watching link right down there in the
description i am begging you to give
this game a try
not enough people play this game it is
so
much fun thank you
and as always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
you